The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: The last time we
talked about nondeterministic
programming.
And I think actually the
mic is up pretty high.
If we can tone that down
just a little bit.
We talked about nondeterministic
programming.
And as you recall, the rule
with nondeterministic
programming is you should
never do it
unless you have to.
Today we're going to talk about
synchronizing with locks.
And it goes doubly that you
should never synchronize
without locks unless
you have to.
There's some good reasons for
synchronizing without
locks as we'll see.
But it, once again, becomes even
more difficult to test
correctness and to ensure that
the program that you think
you've written is, in
fact, the program
you meant to write.
So we're going to talk
about a bunch of
really important topics.
The first is memory
consistency.
And then we'll talk a little bit
about lock free protocols
and one of the problems that
arises called the AVA problem.
And then we're going to talk
about a technology that we're
using in the Cilk++ system,
which tries to make an end run
around some of these problems
and allows you to do
synchronization without locks,
with low overhead.
But it only works in
certain context.
So we're going to start with
memory consistency.
So here is a very simple
parallel program.
So initially a and
b are both 0.
And processor zero
moves a 1 into a.
And then it moves whatever
is in location b
into the EBX register.
Processor one does something
complementary.
It moves a 1 into b.
And then it moves whatever is
in a into the EAX register.
Into the EAX register as opposed
to the EBX register.
And the question is what are the
final possible values of
EAX and EBX after both
processors have executed.
Seems like a straightforward
enough question.
What values can EAX and EBX
have, depending upon-- there
may be scheduling of when things
happen and so forth.
So it's not always going to
give the same answer.
But the question is what's
the set of answers
that you can get?
Well, it turns out you can't
just answer this question for
any particular machine
without knowing the
machine's memory model.
So it depends upon how memory
operations behave in the
parallel computer system.
And different machines have
different memory models.
And we'll give you different
answers for this code.
There'll be some answers that
you get on some machines,
different answers on
different machines.
So probably the bedrock of
memory models is a model
called sequential consistency.
And this is intuitively what
you might think you want.
So Lamport in 1979 said, "The
result of any execution is the
same as if the operations of
all the processors were
executed in some sequential
order, and the operations of
each individual processor appear
in this sequence in the
order specified by
its program."
So what does that mean?
So what it says is that if
I look at the processor's
program and the sequence of
operations that are issued by
that processor's program,
they're interleaved with the
corresponding sequences
defined by the other
processors to produce a
global linear order.
So the first thing is that
there's a global linear order
that consists of all of these
processors' instructions being
interleaved.
In this linear order, whenever
you perform a load from memory
into register, it receives the
value that was stored by the
most recent store operation in
that linear order to that
location, i.e. it's memory.
So you don't get something if
you have in this linear order
that two processors wrote.
Well, one of them came last.
The most recent one before
you read, that's the
one that you get.
Now, there may be
many different
interleavings and so forth.
And you could get any of the
values that correspond to any
of those interleavings.
But the point is that you
must get a value that is
represented by some
interleaving.
The hardware can then do
anything it wants, but for the
execution to satisfy the
sequential consistency model,
for it to be sequentially
consistent, must appear as if
the loads and storage obey
some global linear order.
So let's be concrete about that
with the problem that I
gave before.
So initially, we have
a and b are 0.
And now, we have these
instructions executed.
So what I have to do is say, I
get any possible outcome based
on interleaving these
instructions in this order.
So if I look at it, I've
got two instructions
here, two over here.
So that there are six possible
interleavings because 4 choose
2 is 6 for those people
who've taken 6042.
So there are six possible
interleavings.
So for example, if I execute
first move a 1 into a, and
then I execute move load into
register, the value of b, and
then I move 1 into b, and then I
load the value of a, I get a
value of 1 for EAX and
a value of 0 for EBX.
For this particular interleaving
of those
instructions.
That's what happens if
I execute these two
before these two.
If I execute these two
instructions here before these
two here, I get the
order 3412.
And essentially, the opposite
thing happens.
EAX gets 0 and EBX gets 1.
And then, if I interleave them
in some way, where 1 and 3
somehow come first before I do
the 2 and 4, then I'll get a
value of 11 for each of them.
Those are the middle cases.
So what don't I get?
AUDIENCE: 00
PROFESSOR: You never
gets 00 in a
sequentially consistent execution.
Sequential consistent implies
that no execution--
whoops, that should be EAX.
That EAX equals EBX equals 0.
I don't ever get that outcome.
If I did, then I would say my
machine wasn't sequentially
consistent.
So now let me take a detour a
little bit to look at mutual
exclusion again.
And understand what happens to
mutual exclusion algorithms in
the context of memory
consistency.
So everybody understood what
sequential consistency is.
I simply look at my program
as if I'm interleaving
instructions.
So most implementations of
mutual exclusion, as I showed
previously, employ some kind of
atomic read-modify-write.
So the example I gave you last
time was using the exchange
operation to atomically exchange
a value in a register
with a value in memory.
People remember that?
To implement a lock?
So in order to implement
a lock, I
atomically switch two values.
So we, in particular, use
the exchange one.
And there are a bunch of other
commands that people can use.
Test-and-set, compare-and-swap,
load-linked-store-conditional,
which essentially do some kind
of read-modify-write
on memory.
These tend to be expensive
instructions, as I mentioned.
They usually tend to
cost something
like an L2 cache hit.
Now, the question is can
mutual exclusion be
implemented with only atomic
loads and stores?
Do you really need one of these
heavyweight operations
to implement mutual exclusion?
What if I don't use our
read-modify-write?
Is that possible to do it?
And in fact, the
answer is yes.
So Dekker and Dijksra show that
it can as long as the
computer system is sequentially
consistent.
So as long as you have
sequential consistency, you in
fact, can implement a mutual
exclusion with
read-modify-write.
We're actually not going to
use either the Dekker or
Dijksra algorithms, although
you can read about those in
the literature.
We're going to look at what is
probably the simplest such
algorithm that's been devised
to date, which
is devised by Peterson.
And I'm going to illustrate
it with these two smileys.
That's a she.
And that's a he.
And they want to operate
on widget x.
And she wants to frob it.
And he wants to borf it.
And we want to preserve the
property that we are not
frobbing and borfing
at the same time.
So how do we do that?
Well, here's the code.
So we're going to set up some
things before we start he and
she operating.
So we're going to have
our widget x.
That's our protected variable.
And we're going to have a
Boolean set initially to false
that says whether she
wants to frob it.
So we don't want to make them
frob it unless they
want to frob it.
And we don't want him to borf it
unless he wants to borf it.
And we're going to have an
extra auxiliary variable,
which is whose turn it is.
So they're going to sort
of do a take turn.
But that only is going to come
into account if the other one
doesn't have a conflict.
If they don't have a conflict,
then one of them is going to
be able to go.
So here's what she
basically does.
She initially sets
that she wants to
operate on the widget.
And then, what she does is she
sets the turn to be his.
And then, while he wants it,
and the turn is his, she's
going to just spin.
Notice that you're not frobbing
it in while loop.
The body of the while
loop is empty.
So this is a spinning
solution.
So while he wants it, and it's
his turn, you're just going to
sit there, continually testing
the variables he wants and
turn equals his until one of
them ends up being false.
So if he doesn't want it, or
it's not his turn, then she
gets to frob it.
And when she's done, she sets
she wants to false.
And he does a similar thing.
He sets it to true, says
it's her turn.
And then, while she wants it,
and the turn is hers, just
sits there waiting, continually
re-executing this
until finally, one of these
turns out to be false.
And then he borfs it.
And he sets it to false.
And then, they're doing both of
these things sort of in a
loop, periodically coming
back and executing it.
And what you want to do is you
don't want to make it so that
it's forced.
That it's one turn, then the
other because maybe he never
wants to borf it.
And then, she would be stuck
not being able to frob it,
even though he doesn't want.
So if you think about this--
let's think about why this
always is going to give
you mutual exclusion.
So basically, what's happening
here is if he wants it--
by the way, these things are
not easy to reason about.
And usually, as much as I can
talk and talk in class, what
you really need to do is go
home, and sit down with this
kind of thing.
And study it for 10 minutes.
And then, you'll understand
what the subtleties are as
what's going on.
But basically, what we're doing
is we're making it so
that it's not going to be the
case that both she's setting
it and she wants it.
And the turn is his.
And then, if there's a race
where he wants it also, then
that's going to preclude both of
them from going into it at
the same time.
And then whichever one sets
the turn, one of those is
going to occur first.
And one is going to
occur second.
And whoever ends up coming
second, the other
one gets to go ahead.
So it's very subtle how that
is actually working to make
sure that each one is gating the
other to allow them to go.
But the way to reason about this
is to reason about it is
what are the possible
interleavings?
And the important interleavings
here as you can
see are what happens when
setting these things.
And once they're set,
what happens in
testing these things?
And especially because when you
go around the loop and so
forth, you have to imagine
that an arbitrarily long
amount of time is gone.
So for example, between the time
that you check that the
turn is his, he may have already
gone around this loop.
And so you have to
worry about--
even though, it may look like
one instruction from this
processors point of view for
correctness purpose, you have
to imagine that an arbitrary
amount of computation could
occur between any two
instructions.
So any question about
this code?
People see how it preserves
mutual exclusion and how you
use sequential consistency to
reason about it by asking what
are the possible
interleavings?
Questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So, I don't know
if I got it right.
So basically, sets the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to give him a chance before
she goes to loop.
So basically, she waits there
until he has been able to go?
That's why on the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So on this
third line--
AUDIENCE: Both of them.
Either before actually
frobbing or borfing.
And before that while you always
give the turn to the
other to give them
a chance to go.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So there are two things
you want to show.
One is that they can't
both be stalled on
the while loop there.
And that can't happen because
the turn can't be
simultaneously his and hers.
So you know that they're not
both going to deadlock in
trying to do this by sitting
there waiting for the other
because of this.
And now, the question is well,
how do you know that one can't
get through while the other
is also going through?
And for that, you have to look
and say, oh well, if you go
through, then you know that it
is either he doesn't want it,
or it's not his turn.
And in which case, if
he doesn't want it,
it's not his turn.
If he does change it to that
he wants it, then in fact,
it's going to be your turn.
Question?
AUDIENCE: This only works for
exactly two threads, right?
PROFESSOR: This only works
for exactly two threads.
This does not work for three,
but there are extensions of
this sort of thing to
end threads in an
arbitrary large number.
However, the data structures
to implement this kind of
mutual exclusion for end threads
end up taking space
proportional to n.
And so one of the advantages
of the built in atomics--
the compare-and-swap, or the
atomic exchange, or whatever--
is they work for an arbitrary
number of threads with only a
bounded amount of resource.
You don't require extra data
structures and so forth.
So that's why they put those
things in the architecture
because in the architecture you
can build things that will
solve this problem much
more simply than
this sort of thing.
However, there are going to be
lessons here that you may want
to use in your programming,
depending
on what you're doing.
So now, it turns out that
no modern day processor
implements sequential
consistency.
There have been machines that
were built-- actually quite
good machines--
that implemented sequential
consistency.
But today, nobody
implements it.
They all implement some form
of what's called relaxed
consistency, where the
hardware may reorder
instructions.
And so you have things
executing
not in program order.
And the compilers may reorder
instructions as well.
So both the hardware and the
software are going in there.
So let's take a look at that.
So here's the program order
for one of the things.
We move 1 into a, and then move
the value of b into EBX
to do a load.
Here's the program order.
Most modern hardware will switch
these and execute it in
this order.
Why do you suppose?
Even if you write it this way,
the instruction level
parallelism within the processor
will, in fact,
execute it in the opposite
order most of the time.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because loading
takes longer.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Because loading takes longer.
Loading is going to
take latency.
I can't complete the load from
the processor's point of view
until I get an answer.
So if I load, and I wait for
it to go out to the memory
system and back into
the processor,
and then I do a store--
well, as soon as I've done
the store, I can move on.
Even if the store takes
a while to get out
to the memory system.
But if I do it in the
opposite order.
I do the store first, and then
I do the load, I've ended up
wasting essentially one cycle,
the cycle to do the store,
when I could have been
overlapping that with the time
it took to do the load.
So people follow that?
So if I execute the load first,
I can go right on to
execute the store.
I can issue the load, go right
on to execute the store
without having to wait for the
load to complete if I have a
multi-issue CPU in the
processor core.
So you get higher instruction
level parallelism.
Now when is it safe for the
hardware compiler to perform
this reordering?
Can it always switch
instructions like this to put
loads before stores?
When would this be a bad idea to
put a load before a store?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You're loading the
variable you just stored.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, if
you're loading the
variable you just stored.
Suppose you say store into
x and then load from x.
That's different from if
I load from x, and then
I store into x.
So if you're going to the same
location, then that's not a
safe thing to do.
So basically, in this case, if a
is not equal to b, then this
is safe to do.
But if a equals b, this
is not safe to do.
Because it's going to give
you a different answer.
However, it turns out that
there's another time when this
is not safe to do.
So this would have been the end
of the story if we were
running on one processor.
The other time that it's
not safe to do it is--
if it's safe, the other
assumption is that there's no
concurrency.
If there is concurrency, you can
run into trouble as well.
And the reason is because
another processor may be
changing the value that you're
planning to read.
And so if you read things out
of order, you may violate
sequential consistency.
Let me show you what's going on
in the hardware so you have
an appreciation of what
the issue is here.
So here's 30,000 feet of
hardware reordering.
So the processor is going to
issue memory operations to the
memory system.
And results of memory
operations are
going to come back.
But they really only have
to come back when?
If they're loads.
If they're stores, they don't
have to come back.
So the processor, in fact, can
issue stores faster than the
network can handle them.
And the memory system
can handle them.
So the processors are
generally very fast.
The memory systems are
relatively slow.
But the processor is not
generally issuing a store on
every cycle.
It may do store, it may do
some additions, it may do
another store, et cetera.
So rather than waiting for the
memory system to do every
store, they create
a store buffer.
And the memory system pulls
things out of the store buffer
as fast as it can.
And the processor shoves stuff
into the store buffer up to
the point that the store buffer
gets full, in which
case it would have to stall.
But for most many codes, it
never has to stall because
there is a sufficient frequency
of other operations
going on that you don't
have to wait.
So when a store occurs, it
doesn't occur immediately on
the store buffer.
Now along comes a
load operation.
And the load operation, if it's
to a different address,
you want to have that take
priority because the processor
can be waiting.
It's next instructions may
be waiting on the result.
So you want that to go
as fast as possible.
They have a passing lane here
where the fast cars or the
important cars, the ambulances,
et cetera, in this
case loads, can scoot by all
the other things in traffic
and get to the memory
system first.
But as we said, we don't want
to do that if the last thing
that I stored was to
the same address.
So in fact, there is content
addressable memory here, which
matches the address that is
being loaded with everything
in the store buffer.
And if it does match, it gets
satisfied immediately by the
store buffer.
And only does it make it out to
the network if it's not in
the store buffer.
But what you can see here is
that this mechanism, which
works great on one processor,
violates sequential
consistency because I may have
operations going to two
different memory locations,
where the order, in fact,
matters to me.
So let's see how
that works out.
So first of all, let me tell you
what the memory can-- so a
load can bypass a store
to different address.
First of all, any questions
about this mechanism?
So this accounts for a whole
bunch of understanding of what
happens in concurrency
in systems.
This one understanding
of store buffers.
It's absolutely crucial.
And I have talked, by the way,
with lots of experts who don't
understand this.
That this is what's going
on for why we don't have
sequential consistency
in our computers.
It's because they made the
decision to allow this
optimization, even though it
doesn't preserve sequential
consistency.
There were machines in the
past that did support
sequential consistency.
And what they did was they used
speculation to allow the
processor to assume that it was
sequentially consistent.
And if that turned out to be
wrong, they were able to roll
back the processor's state
to the point before
the access was done.
In fact, the processor is
already doing that for
branches, where it makes
branch predictions and
executes down a line.
But it's wrong, it
has to flush the
pipeline and so forth.
Why they don't do the same
thing for hardware is an
interesting--
for loads of stores-- is an
interesting question.
Because at some level
there's no reason
they couldn't do this.
Instead, it's sort of been a
thing where the software
people say, yeah we
can handle it.
And the hardware
people say, OK.
You're willing to handle it.
We won't worry about it then.
When in fact, it just makes life
complicated for everybody
that you don't have sequential
consistency.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
you have to do speculation
across both [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well here, you only
have to do speculation over
what actually is coming out
of your memory system.
And if it doesn't match,
you could roll back.
The issue, in part, is how many
machine states are you
ready to roll back to.
Loads come more frequently
than branches.
That's one thing.
So no doubt, there are
good reasons for why
they're doing it.
Nevertheless, definitely loss
of sequential consistency
becomes a headache for a lot
of people in doing a
concurrent program.
We had a question here?
Yes, Sara?
AUDIENCE: So this does not
preserve sequential
consistency?
But as long as there's only one
processor, it should have
the same effect, right?
PROFESSOR: But sequential
consistency for one processor
is easy because all you
do is execute them--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm
just saying--
PROFESSOR: It should have the
same effect, exactly.
So on one processor, this
works perfectly well.
If there's no concurrency, this
is going to give you the
same behavior.
And yet, you've now got this
optimization that loads can
bypass stores.
And therefore, you can do a
store and a load and be able
to overlap their execution.
So this definitely wins
for serial execution.
Yep, good.
Any other questions about
this mechanism?
You could reason about
it on the quiz.
That kind of thing, right?
Yeah, OK?
So here's the x86 memory
consistency model.
For many years, Intel was
unwilling to say what their
memory consistency model was
for fear that people would
then rely on it.
And then, they would
be forced into it.
But recently, they've started
being more explicit about it.
And this is the large
part of it.
I haven't put up all the things
because there are a
whole bunch of instructions,
such as locking instructions
and so forth, for which for
some of them, it's more
complicated.
But this is the basics.
So loads are not reordered
with loads.
So if you add a load to one
location, a load to another
location, they always execute
in the same order.
Stores are not reordered
with stores.
If you have store and then a
subsequent store, those two
stores always go
in that order.
Stores are not reordered
with prior loads.
So if you do a store
after a load--
if you do a load and then a
store, they're going to go in
that order.
However, a load--
and this is what we just
talked about--
may be reordered with a prior
store to a different location
but not with a prior store
to the same location.
So that's exactly what we
just talked about on
the previous slide.
Then, loads and stores are
not reordered with lock
instructions.
So a certain set of instructions
are called lock
instructions.
And they include all the atomic
updates, the exchanges,
comparisons-and-swaps, and
a variety of other atomic
operations that the
hardware supports.
The stores to the same location
always respect a
global order.
Everybody sees the store
to a location in
exactly the same order.
And the lock instructions
respect a global total order.
So that everybody sees that this
thread, or processor, got
a lock before that one.
You don't have two different
processors disagreeing on what
the order was that somebody
acquired a lock or whatever.
And then, memory ordering
preserves transitive
visibility, which
is sort of like
saying it obeys causality.
In other words, if after doing
a, if you had some effect, and
then you did b, it should look
like to other people like a
and then b happened.
Like there's a causality
going on.
But that's not sequential
consistency, mainly
because of four here.
So what's the impact
of reordering?
So here, we have our example
from the beginning for the
memory bottle, where I'm storing
a 1 into a and then
loading whatever is in b.
And similarly, over
here the opposite.
So what happens if I'm allowed
to do reordering?
What can happen to these
two instructions?
Yeah.
They can execute in the
opposite order.
Similarly, these two guys can
execute in the opposite order.
So they can actually execute in
this order where we do the
load and then the stores.
So it executes as if this
were the order.
Did I do this right?
Executes as if this
were the order.
So I could do 1, 2, 3, 4.
So if then, I do the ordering
2, 4, 1, 3.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I got the screwed
up, I think.
Didn't I?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Because I should be
swapping these guys, right?
AUDIENCE: Swapped the
wrong [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Ugh.
OK.
So if I did this
one 2, 1, 4, 3.
So ignore this thing.
Suppose I do the order 2.
So basically, I load b.
Then, I load a.
Then, I store a.
And then, I store b.
What's the result value that
are in EAX and EBX?
You get 00.
Remember 00 wasn't the legal
value from sequential
consistency.
But in this case, the Intel
architecture and many other
architectures out there will
give you the wrong value for
the execution of these
instructions.
Any question about that?
So it doesn't preserve
sequential consistency.
So that's kind of scary in some
way because you got to
reason about this.
Let's see what happens in
Peterson's algorithm if you
don't have sequential
consistency.
So here we go.
We have the code where
she wants is true,
turn is his, et cetera.
How is this going to fail?
What could happen here?
Where will the bug arise?
What's going to happen?
What's the reordering
that might happen?
AUDIENCE: On the while
you do loads, right?
[INAUDIBLE] the he_wants
and turn is.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: On the while
statement,
you do a load, right?
Because [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
He_wants is a load.
AUDIENCE: And so that
will get reordered.
PROFESSOR: Where could
that be reordered to?
That could be reordered all
the way to the top.
Similarly, this one can
be reordered all
the way to the top.
So the loads could be ordered
all the way to the top.
And now, what's going to happen
is you're going to set
that she_wants is true but
get a value of he_wants
that might be old.
And so they won't see
each other's values.
And so then, both threads can
now enter the critical section
simultaneously.
Yeah, Reid?
AUDIENCE: If you swap the order
of the loads, does the
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: If you swap the
order of the loads--
AUDIENCE: If you swap-- put
the turn equals his on the
left, [INAUDIBLE]
on the right.
Because according to--
PROFESSOR: Put the turn
equals his over here?
AUDIENCE: Because the he_wants
can't cross the load.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but that's
not what you want to do.
AUDIENCE: Then you can't
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The whole idea here
is that when you're saying you
want to do something, you give
the other one a turn so that
whoever ends up winning the race
allows just one of them
to go through.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think the point is
that if you put turn equals
his and he_wants--
PROFESSOR: You're saying
this stuff here.
AUDIENCE: Swap those two
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] turn equals
his will not be reordered
before the store that--
PROFESSOR: You might be right.
Let me think about that.
AUDIENCE: You both reorder
the same [? word. ?]
AUDIENCE: But you just
stored turn, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So if do turn equals his--
I see what you're saying.
Do this turn equals his.
I was looking at this
turn equals his.
AUDIENCE: You mean turn
equals equals his.
AUDIENCE: So the Boolean
expression [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK, I hadn't thought
about that.
Let me just think about
that a second.
So if we do the turn
equals his--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
and you won't reorder those
two [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Then the--
Yeah.
You got to be--
I have to think about that.
I don't know about you folks,
but I find this stuff really
hard to think about.
And so do most people,
I think.
This is one of these things
where I don't think I can do
without sitting down
for 10 minutes and
thinking about it deeply.
But it's an interesting thought
that if you did it the
other direction that maybe
there would be
a requirement there.
I'm skeptical that that is true
because to my knowledge
to do the mutual exclusion,
you pretty much have to do
what I'm going to
talk about next.
But it would be interesting
if is true.
Because you also have to worry
about this guy getting
reordered with respect
to this one.
AUDIENCE: The loads can't
be reordered with
respect to each other.
PROFESSOR: So he_wants
and turn equals his.
Yeah.
So the loads won't
be reordered.
Yeah.
So that looks OK.
And then, you're saying and then
therefore, it can't go
forward because this one won't
get reordered with that one.
You might be right.
That'd be cute.
So I have to update the slides
for next year if that's true.
So one way out of this quandary
is to use what's
called a memory fence
or memory barrier.
And it's a hardware action
that enforces an ordering
constraint between the
instructions before
and after the fence.
So a memory fence says don't
allow the processor to reorder
these things.
So why would you not want
to do a memory fence?
Then we'll talk about
why you do it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: To force a
hardware slowdown?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You're forcing the hardware
slowdown.
You're also forcing compiler
because the compiler has to
respect that, too.
You're not letting the compiler
do optimizations
across the fence.
So generally, fences
slow things down.
In addition, it turns
out that they have
some significant overhead.
So you can issue a memory
fence explicitly as an
instruction.
So the mfence instruction
sets a memory fence.
There's also, it turns out, on
x86 an lfence and an sfence,
which allow loads to go over
but not stores and
stores but not loads.
And this one is basically
both.
From the point of view of what
we're using it for, we're only
going to worry about
the fences.
They're done by the
explicit one.
But it also turns out all
the locking instructions
automatically put a fence in.
One of the humorous things
in recent memory is major
manufacturers for whom the lock
instruction was actually
faster than doing a memory
fence, which is kind of weird
because a lock instruction
does a memory fence.
So how do you think that sort
of thing comes about?
So when you looked at
performance it would be like--
for this particular machine
I'm thinking about--
it was 30 cycles to do
a lock instruction.
And it was on the order of 50
cycles to do a memory fence.
And so if you want to
do a memory fence,
what should you do?
AUDIENCE: Do a lock.
PROFESSOR: Do a lock
instruction
instead to get the effect.
But why do you suppose that
came up in the hardware?
Why is it that one instruction
would be--
It's a social reason why this
sort of thing happens.
So I don't know for sure.
But I know enough about
engineering to understand how
these things come about.
So here's what goes on.
They do studies of traces
of programs.
And how often do you think
lock instructions occur?
fence instructions occur?
Turns out lock instructions
occur all the time, whereas
fences, they don't occur so
often because usually it's
somebody who really knows what
they're doing who's using a
memory fence.
So then, they say to the
engineering team, we're going
to make our code go faster.
And lock instructions are
going really fast.
So they put a top engineer
on making lock
instructions go fast.
They put a second-rate engineer
on making memory
fence operations go fast because
they're not used as
often, without sort of
recognizing that, gee, what
you do for one is the
same problem.
You can do the same thing
for the other.
So it ends up you'll see things
in architecture that
are really quite humorous like
that, where things are sort of
like, wait a minute, how come
this is slower when well, it
probably has to do with the
engineering team that built
the system.
And actually now I'm aware of
two architectures where they
did the same kind of thing by
different manufacturers.
Where they got these
memory fences.
It should be at least as fast
because the one is doing--
anyway.
Interesting story there.
Now, you can actually access a
memory fence using a built in
function called sync
synchronize.
And in fact, there whole
set of atomics--
I've put the information here
for where you can go and look
at the atomic operations that
include memory fences and so
forth to using in
the compiler.
It turns out when I was trying
to get this going last night,
I couldn't get it to work.
And it turns out that's because
our compiler had a bug
where this instruction was
compiling to nothing.
There's a compiler bug.
And so I messed around for far
too much time and then finally
sent out a help message
to the T.A.s.
And then, John figured out
that there was a bug.
And he's patched all the
compilers so that you
guys all have it.
But anyway, it was like, how
come this isn't working?
AUDIENCE: What compiler
are we using?
PROFESSOR: This was GCC.
I was trying 4 1,
and I tried 4 3.
And so the one that we're using
in class for the most
part, is 4 3.
So anyway, John put
the patch in.
So now, when you use these
instructions, they're all there.
And then, the last thing is
that the typical cost of a
memory fence operation is
comparable to that of an L2
cache access.
So memory fences tend to
be on our machine--
and I haven't actually measured
in our machine.
I meant to do that, and I
didn't get around to it.
It's probably on the order
of 10, or 15 cycles, or
something, which is not bad.
If it's less than 20,
it's pretty good.
So here's Peterson's algorithm
with memory fences.
You just simply sticky in the
memory fence there to prevent
the reordering.
And it's interesting if there's
a way that we can play
the game with the instruction
stream to do the same thing
because that would make this
code go, generally, a lot
faster in terms of overhead.
And so using memory fences, you
can restore consistency.
Now, memory fences are
like data races.
If you don't have them,
how do you know that
you don't have them.
It's very difficult to
regression test for them,
which is one reason I
think there was a
bug in the GCC compiler.
How do you know that some
piece of code is failing
because most of the time
it will work correctly.
It's just occasionally, they'll
be some reordering,
and timing, and race condition
that causes
it not to work out.
In this case, you both have
to have the race and the
reordering happening at the
same time for Peterson's
algorithm, for example.
So compilers can be
very difficult
for things like this.
Really, the way to do it, which
is what I was doing, was
do an objdump and search
for is fence in there.
And in this case, it
wasn't in there.
AUDIENCE: And also compiler's
self-analyzers, by itself.
And that's this instruction that
basically can take code.
PROFESSOR: Right.
It's not doing anything.
Right.
So it says, oop, get out of it.
Yep.
Good.
So any questions about
consistency.
So what turns out to be most
of the time when you're
designing things where you want
to synchronize through
memory directly, rather than
using locks or what have you.
The methodology that I found
works pretty well.
Work it out for sequential
consistency, and then figure
out where you have to
put the fences in.
And that's a pretty
good methodology
for working out where--
here's sequential consistency.
Now, what reorderings do I need
to ensure in order to
make sure that it
works properly.
And that can be error prone.
So once again, big skull and
cross bones on whether you
actually try this in practice.
It really better make
a difference.
Now, the fact that you can
synchronize directly through
memory has led to a lot of
protocols that are called
lock-free protocols, which have
some advantages, even
though, in particular, because
they don't use locks.
And so I want to illustrate some
of those because you'll
see these in certain places.
So recall the summing problem
from last time.
So here we have an array.
And what we're going to do is
run through all the elements
in the array, computing
something on every element,
and adding into result.
And we wanted to parallelize
that.
So we parallelize that
with a Cilk 4.
And what was the problem when
we parallelize this?
We get a race.
So there's the race.
We get a race on result because
we've got two parallel
instructions both
trying to update
results at the same time.
So we can solve that
with a lock.
And I showed you last
time that we could
solve this for lock.
By declaring a mutex, and then
locking before we update the
results, and then unlock.
And of course, as we argued
yesterday, that could cause
severe contention.
Now, contention can
be an issue.
But if it turns out that the
compute here, which I've moved
outside the lock notice.
I've put it into temp and then
added temp in so I can lock
for the shortest
possible time.
If this compute is sufficiently
large, there may
be contention.
But it may not be a significant
contention in your
execution because the update
here could be very, very short
compared with the time
it takes to compute.
So for example, if computing on
array i cost you more than
say order n time, then the fact
that you have contention
there isn't going to matter,
generally, because the total
amount of time that you're going
to be locking is just
small compared to the total
execution time.
Still in a multiprogram setting,
there may be other
problems that you can get into,
even when you have this
and even if you think
that contention
is going to be minimal.
So can anybody think of what
the issues might be?
Why could this be problematic
even if contention
is not a big issue?
And the hint here is it's in
a multiprogram setting.
So what happens in a
multiprogram setting.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Because
the resolve is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: It actually doesn't
have to do with resolve here.
It has to do with locking
explicitly.
It's a problem with locking in a
multiprogrammed environment.
What happens in a
multiprogrammed environment?
What do I mean by
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Have multiple
jobs running, right?
And what happens to the
processor when there are
multiple jobs running?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Contact switches.
So now, what can
go wrong here?
What can be really bad here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You aquire the
lock and then the
contacts switch out.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You acquire the lock.
And then, the operating system
contact switches you out.
And so what happens?
You hold the lock while some
other job is running.
And what are those guys doing.
They go and spin and
wait on the lock.
Now, this is a good time where
you'd rather not have a
spinning lock.
You'd rather have
a yielding lock.
But even so, suddenly you're
talking about something that's
operating at the level of
100 times a second, 10
milliseconds, versus something
that is operating on a
nanosecond level.
So you're talking six orders
of magnitude of performance
difference if you end up getting
switched out while you
hold a lock.
That's the issue.
What happens.
And then, if that happens,
all the other loop
iterations must wait.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
in the large program here
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
I don't have a mic.
If one [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
crashes or one
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
the lock
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
AUDIENCE: Can you specify
whether those are yielding
locks or spinning locks?
PROFESSOR: Usually, the mutex
type will tell you.
I'm just using a simple
name of mutex.
I probably should have been
using the ones that--
we were using one called
Cilk mutex.
And I probably should've used
that here rather than just
simple mutex.
AUDIENCE: Are they yielding?
PROFESSOR: There's
a good question.
I used to know the
answer to this.
I believe that those spin for
a while, are competitive.
They spin for a while
and then yield.
But I'm not sure.
They may just spin.
They don't just automatically
yield.
They're either competitive,
or they'll spin and yield.
I believe they spin and yield.
And I believe there's actually
a switch where
you can tell it--
if you're doing timing
measurements--
make it so that it purely spins
so that you can get
better benchmark results.
AUDIENCE: So my question is does
the colonel have power to
switch out a spinning
lock or not?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Well, the colonel, the
scheduler, can come in at any
moment and say, whip
you're out.
You're out.
That's it.
And wherever it is, it
interrupts it at
that moment in time.
So one solution to this
problem is to
use a lock-free method.
And one of the common ways of
doing that is with what's
called compare-and-swap
instruction.
So this is what's called a
locking instruction, meaning
it's one of these ones that goes
out to L2, in terms of
timing and so forth.
And what it does is it does
the following thing.
It has an address
of a location.
And it's got the old value
that was stored in the
location and a new value.
And it says if the value that
is there is the old value,
well, then stick the
new value in there.
And then return essentially
true.
Otherwise return false.
So it's basically saying what
you tend to do is you first
look to see what's the value.
You then update the value.
And then you say, if it hasn't
changed, stick it back in and
return true.
If it has changed,
return false.
So it's only swaps the
value if it is true.
There's actually two versions.
One which says bool and
one which says val.
And if you do the bool version,
it returns a flag.
If you do the val version, it
actually returns the value
that was in there.
So it's more like a
compare-and-swap.
The main thing about this is
this code essentially executes
atomically with the single
instruction, which is called--
The instruction is cmpxchg.
Is it up there?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah.
So the cmpxchg instruction
on x86.
So when you compile this, you
should find on your assembly
output that instruction
somewhere unless the compiler
figures out a better way
to optimize that.
But generally, you
should find that.
Also, one of the things about
this is it works on values
that are sort of integer
type values.
But it doesn't work on floating
point numbers, in
particular.
So you can't compare-and-swap
a value, which is a floating
point value.
You can only do it with
energy type values.
So let's take a look at how we
can use the compare-and-swap
for the summing problem.
So what we do is we have
the same sort of code.
And now, what I'm going to do is
compute my temporary value.
And then, what I'll do is
I'll read the value
of result into old.
I'll then update my new value
for what I think I want the
result to be the result plus
the thing that I computed.
And now, what I do is I attempt
to compare-and-swap as
long as the old value is
what I read it to be.
Swap in the new value.
If the old value turns out to
be different from what is
currently in the result
location,
then it returns false.
And I redo this again.
Then, I have to redo the
whole loop again.
So this is a do-while loop.
Do-while is like a while loop,
except you do the body first.
And then you test
the condition.
So if this fails, I go back.
I then get a new value for
the result and so forth.
So let me show you
how that works.
Let's see.
So first, I'll show you
how this works.
Actually, I'll show it on a more
interesting example how
this works.
So what happens if I get swapped
out in the middle of a
loop iteration?
All I do is when I do the
compare-and-swap it fails.
So no other instructions
can wait.
They can all march ahead and do
the thing they need to do.
And then, the one that
got swapped out, eh.
It gets some old value.
It discovers that and has
to re-execute the loop.
So is that fine?
So what this means is that the
amount work that's going on,
however, could in fact, be
greater, depending upon how
much contention there is.
If there's a lot of contention,
you could end up
having these guys fighting
and not re
executing a lot of code.
But that's really not much worse
than them spinning is
what it comes down to.
Any questions?
Let's do a more interesting
example.
Here's a lock-free stack.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to have a node,
which has a next pointer
and some data.
All we really care about
is the next pointer.
And we have a stack, which has
basically a head pointer.
So we have a linked list here.
We want to basically be able to
insert things at the front
and take things out
of the front.
So here's a lock-free push.
So remember, this could
be concurrent.
So these guys want to operate
on it at a time.
We saw last time how in doing
very simple updates on link
structures, you could get
yourself into a mess if you
didn't properly synchronize when
we did the insertion in
the hash table.
So here's my push
[? up ?] code.
Well let's walk through it.
It says, basically, here's my
node that I want to insert.
It says, first of all, make
node.next point to the head.
So we basically have
it pointing to 77.
So then what we say is OK.
Let's compare-and-swap to make
the head point to the node but
only if the value of the
head has not changed.
It's still the value
of the node.next.
And if so, it does the swap.
Question?
AUDIENCE: You say
compare-and-swap.
But you compare it to what?
PROFESSOR: PROFESSOR: In this
case it's comparing to the--
so this is basically the
location that you're doing the
compare-and-swap on, the old
value that you expect to see
in that location, and
the new value.
So here, what it says--
when we're at this
point here--
we're saying before you do the
compare-and-swap, we're
saying, I only want you to set
that pointer to go to here if
this value is still
pointing to there.
So only move this here if
this value is still 77.
In other words, if somebody
else came in--
well, I'll do an example in a
second that shows what happens
when we have concurrency, and
one of them might fail.
But if it is true, then
it basically sets it.
And now I'm home free.
So let's take a look at what
happens when we have
contention.
So I have two guys.
So 33 says, OK I'll come in.
Let me set my next pointer
to the head.
But then comes 81.
And it says, OK.
Let me try to set my pointer to
also be 77 because I look
at what the head is,
and that's where
it's supposed to go.
So now, what happens
is we do the
compare-and-swap operation.
And they both are going
to try to do it.
And one of them is going to,
essentially, do it first
because the hardware preserves
that the compare-and-swaps,
their locking operations,
they will happen in
some definite order.
So in this case, 81 got
in there and did its
compare-and-swap first.
When it looked, 77 was still
a value that it said.
So it allowed that pointer
to be changed.
But now what happens
when 33 tries.
33 tries to do the
compare-and-swap.
And the compare-and-swap fails
because it's saying, I want to
swap 33 in as long as the value
of head is the pointer
to 70, the node was 77.
The value is no longer the
pointer to the node of 77.
It's now the pointer to the
value of the node with 81.
So the compare-and-swap fails.
People follow that?
And so what does
33 have to do?
It's got to start again.
So it goes back around the loop,
and now it sets it to
81, which is now the head.
And now, it can compare-and-swap
in the value.
And they both get in there
perfectly well.
Question?
AUDIENCE: What if there's
[INAUDIBLE]?
What if two nodes have--
PROFESSOR: Well, notice here,
it's not looking at the value
of the data.
Nowhere does data appear here.
It's actually looking
at the address of
this chunk of memory.
There is a similar problem,
which I will
raise in just a moment.
There is still a problem.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: So I'm confused
about the interface.
So you give it the address
of where you want to
compare the value of.
And you're giving it what
you're pointing at and--
PROFESSOR: And here's the value
that I expect to be
stored in this location.
The value I expect to be in
there is node dot next.
So if I go back a
couple things.
Here.
Here, the guy says, the
value I expect to be
there is in this case.
the address of this chunk
of memory here.
He expects the address of the
node containing 77 is going to
be in this location.
It's not.
What's in this location
is the address of
this chunk of memory.
But you're saying, if it's equal
to this, then you can go
ahead and do the swap.
Otherwise you're
going to fail.
And the swap consists of now
sticking this value into--
conditionally sticking
it in there.
So you either do it or
you don't do it.
So let's now do a pop.
So pop you can also
do with things.
So here, I'm going to want
to extract an element.
And what I'm going to do is
create a current value that I
want to make point to the
element that gets eliminated.
So what I do is I say, well,
the element that I want is
that guy there.
And now, what I want to do is
make the head jump around and
point to 94.
So what I do is I say, well,
as long as the--
and I want to do that unless I
get down to the fact that I
have an empty list.
So basically, I say, if
the head still has
the value of current--
so they're pointing to
the same place--
then, I want to move in
current arrow next.
And then I'm done.
Otherwise, I want to set current
to head, reset it, and
go back to the beginning
and try to pop again.
And I'm going to keep doing
that until I get my pop to
succeed or until current
points to nil.
If it ended up at the end,
then I don't want to keep
popping if the list ended
up being empty.
So basically, it sets that
one to jump over.
And now, once it's done that, I
can go, and I can clean up,
I can get rid of this
pointer, et cetera.
But nobody else who's coming in
to use this link list, can
see 15 now because I'm the only
one with a pointer to it.
So people understand that?
So where's the bug?
Turns out this has a but
after all that work.
Each of these individually does
what it's supposed to do.
But here's the bug.
And it's a famous problem
because you see it all the
time when people are
synchronizing through memory
with lock-free algorithms.
It's called the ABA problem.
So here's the problem.
And it's similar to what
some people were
concerned about earlier.
So here's the ABA problem.
Thread 1 begins to pop 15.
So imagine that what it does is
it sets its current there,
and then it reads the value
here, and starts to set the
head here using the
compare-and-swap.
But it doesn't complete the
compare-and-swap yet.
The compare-and-swap
hasn't executed.
It's simply gotten this
value, and it's
about to swap it here.
So then, thread 2 comes along.
And it says, oh, I want to
pop something as well.
So it comes in.
And it turns out it's faster,
and manages to pop 15 off, and
set up its pointers.
Now, what would normally
happen here is if this
completed, what would happen?
The compare-and-swap instruction
would discover
that this pointer is no longer
the pointer to the head.
And so it would fail.
We'd be all hunky dory.
No problem.
But what could actually
happen here?
Thread 2 keeps going on.
It says, oh, let me pop 94.
So it does the same thing.
So thread 1 is still stalled
here, not having completed its
compare-and-swap.
It swaps 94.
Then, thread 2 goes
on and says, oh,
let's put 15 back on.
So it puts 15 back on because
after all, it had 15.
So now, what happens here?
Thread 1 now looks, and it now
completes, and does its
compare-and-swap, it resumes,
splicing out 15, which it
thinks it has.
But it doesn't realize that
other stuff has gone on.
And now, we've got a mess.
So this is the ABA problem
because what happened was we
were checking to see whether the
value was still the same
value, the same chunk
of memory.
It got popped off.
But it got popped back on.
But now, it could be in
any configuration.
We don't know what it is.
And now, the code is thinking,
that oh, nothing happened.
But in fact, something
happened.
So it's ABA because basically,
you've got 15 there.
It goes away.
Then, 15 comes back.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Can you compare two
things and then swap because
that would solve this, right?
PROFESSOR: That's called a
double compare-and-swap.
And we'll talk about
it in a second.
So the classic way to solve
this problem is to use
versioning.
So what you do is you pack a
version number with each
pointer in the same atomically
updatable word.
So that when 15 comes back,
you've got the pointer.
But you also have a version on
that pointer so that the value
has to be the same as
the version you
had and not the value.
What you do is you increment the
version number every time
the pointer is changed.
So you just do an increment.
But you do the compare-and-swap
on the
version number and the pointer
at the same time.
Now, it turns out that some
architectures actually have
what's called a double
compare-and-swap, which will
do compare-and-swap on two
distinct locations.
And that simplifies things even
more because it means you
don't have to pack and
make sure that
things fit in one word.
You can keep versioning
elsewhere.
And there are a whole bunch of
other places where you can, in
fact, optimize and get even
tighter code than you could if
you have to pack.
So that's generally the
way you solve this.
And, of course, you can
see this gets--
as I say, this week has been
skull and cross bones lecture.
It's appropriate it comes right
after Halloween because
really, you do not want
to play these games
unless you have to.
But you should know about them
because you will find times
where you need this, or you need
to understand somebody's
code that they've written
in a lock-free way.
Because remember lock-free has
the nice property that hey,
the operating system swaps
something out, it just keeps
running nice and jolly
if it's correct.
So the other issue is that
version numbers may need to be
very large.
So if you have a version number,
how many bits to you
assign to that version number.
Well, 64 bits, that's
no problem.
You never run out of 64 bits.
2 to the 64th is a very,
very, very big number.
And you'll never run out
of 2 to the 64th.
We did that calculation at the
beginning of the term.
How big did we say it was?
It's pretty big, right?
It's like this big.
Or is it this big?
My two-year-old is this big.
So anyway, it's pretty big.
So is it bigger than--
no, it's not bigger than the
number of particles in the
universe, right?
That's 10 to the 80th,
which is much bigger
than 2 to the 64th.
But it's still a big number.
I think it's like more than
there are atoms in the earth
or something.
It's still pretty big.
You never get through it
if you calculate it.
I think we calculated
it and it was
hundreds of years or whatever.
Anyway, it's a long time.
Many, many, many years at the
very fastest, updating with
biggest supercomputers,
and the most
processors, et cetera.
Never run out of 64 bits.
32 bits.
Four billion.
Maybe you run out.
Maybe you don't.
So that's one of the issues.
You have to say, well, how often
do I have to do that.
Really, you only have
to worry about this.
You can wraparound.
But you've got to make sure
that then you never have a
situation where something could
be swapped out for long
enough that it would come back
and bite you because you're
coming around and then
eating your tail.
And you've got to make sure
you wouldn't have things
overlap and get a [? thing. ?]
So that might be a risk you're
willing to take.
You can do an analysis and
say, what are the odds my
system crashes from
this reason or
from a different reason?
That can be reasonable
engineering trade-off.
So there's an alternative
to compare-and-swap.
One is the double
compare-and-swap.
Another one is some machines
have what's called a
load-linked, store conditional
instruction.
What those are actually is
a pair of instructions.
One is load-linked.
When you load-linked, it
basically says, let's set a
bit, essentially,
in that word.
And if that word ever changes
when you do store conditional,
it will fail.
So even if some other processor
changes it to the
exact same value, it's keeping
track of whether anybody else
wrote it using the memory
consistency mechanism.
The MSI type protocol that
we talked about.
It's using that kind of
mechanism to make sure that if
it changes.
And so this is actually much
more reliable as a mechanism.
x86 does not have load-linked,
store conditional.
I'm not sure why.
I don't know if there's
a patent on it or
what's going on.
But they don't have it.
Final topic is reducers.
So once again, recall
the summing problem.
In Cilk++, they have a mechanism
called reducer
hyperobjects, which lets you do
an end run around some of
these synchronization
problems.
And the basic idea behind it is
we actually could code this
fairly easily as we talked about
last time by just doing
divide and conquer
on the array.
We add up the first half of
the elements, add up the
second half of the elements,
when they
return, add them together.
But the problem is that coding
that is a pain to do.
So the hyper object mechanism
sort of does that
automatically for you.
What you can do is declare
result to be an integer, which
is going to have the operation
add performed on it.
And what happens then is you can
just go ahead and add the
values up like this.
And basically, what it does
is essentially adds things
locally and will combine them
on an as needed basis.
So you don't actually have to do
any synchronization at all.
In the end, you have
to get the result
by doing a get value.
So let me show you a little bit
more what's going on in
this situation.
So the first thing here is
we're saying result is a
summing reducer over int.
The updates are resolved
automatically without races or
contention because they're
basically doing it by keeping
local values and copying them.
And then, at the end, you can
get the underlying value.
So the way this works is that
when you declare the variable,
you're declaring it as a reducer
over some associative
operation, such as addition.
So it only works cleanly if your
operation is associative.
And there are a lot of
associative operations.
Addition, multiplication,
logical, and, list
concatenation.
I can concatenate two lists.
So what does associative mean?
I think I have a slide
on this in a minute.
It means a times b times c.
I can parenthesize it
any way I want and
get the same answer.
Associative, right?
It's not associative like
associative memory or whatever.
So now, the individual strands
in the computation can update
x as if it were an ordinary
non-local variable.
But in fact, it's maintained as
a set of different copies
called views.
The Cilk++ runtime system
coordinates the views and
combines them when
appropriate.
And when only one view remains,
now you can get the
actual value.
So for example, you may have
a summing reducer where the
actual value at this point
in time is 89.
But locally, each processor may
only see a different value
whose sum is 89.
But locally, I could do
something like increment this.
And this guy can independently
increment his view and has the
effect that it increments
whatever the total sum is.
And then, the runtime system
manages to combine everything
at the end to make it be the
value when there's no more
parallelism associated
with that reducer.
So here's the conceptual
behavior.
Imagine I have this code.
I set x equal to 0.
I then add 3.
I then increment.
I had 4, increments at 5.
Fa da da da da.
At the end, I get some
value, which I
don't think I put down.
Another way I could do this
is the following.
Let me do exactly the same here
but with a local view
that I'll call x1.
For this set of operations, let
me start a new view that I
start out with the identity for
addition, which is 0 and
add those guys up.
And then, at the end, let
me add x1 and x2.
It should give me the same
answer if addition is
associative.
In particular, these
now can operate in
parallel with no races.
So if you don't actually look
at the intermediate values--
if all I'm doing is updating
them, but I'm not actually
looking to see what the absolute
value of the thing
is, I should get the same
answer at the end.
The answer to the result
is then determinant.
It's not deterministic because
it's going to get done in a
different way with different
memory state.
But it's determinant, meaning
the output answer is going to
give you the same no matter how
it executes, even if the
resulting computation
is nondeterministic.
So this is a way of
encapsulating, if you will,
nondeterminism.
And it worked because addition
is associative.
It didn't matter which
order I did it.
And once again, I could have
broken it here instead of
there, and I still get
the same answer.
It doesn't matter.
So the idea is as these things
are work stealing around.
they're accumulating things
locally but combining them in
a way that maintains the
invariant that the final value
is going to be the sum.
So there's a lot of other
related work where people do
reduction types of things, but
they're all tied to specific
control or data structures.
And the neat thing about the
Cilk++ version is that it is
not tied to anything.
You can name it anywhere.
You can write recursive
programs.
You can update locally your
reducer wherever you want, and
it figures out exactly how to
combine them in order to get
your final answer.
So the algebraic framework for
this is that we have a monoid,
which is a set, an operator,
and an identity, where the
operator is an associative
binary operator.
And the identity is, in
fact, the identity.
So here are some examples.
Integers with plus and 0, the
real numbers with times and 1,
true and false, Booleans with
and, where true is the
identity, strings over some
alphabet with concatenation,
where the empty string
is the identity.
You can do MAX with minus
infinity as the
operation, and so forth.
And you can come up
with your own.
It's easy to come up with
examples of monoids.
So what we do in Cilk++ is we
represent a monoid over a set
t by a C++ class that inherits
from this base class that's
predefined for you, which is
parameterized using templates
with the types.
So the set that we're going
to use is, in fact,
going to be a type.
And the member function
reduced--
this monoid has to have a member
function reduced that
implements the binary
operator times.
And it also has an identity
member function.
So we set up the algebraic
framework.
So here's, for example, how I
could define a sum monoid.
I inherit from the base with
int, for example, here.
And I define my reduced
function.
And it actually turns out to
be important, you always do
the right one into the left.
Otherwise, you won't have
it be associative.
And then, you have an identity,
which gives you in
this case a new element,
which is 0.
And so you can now define
the reducer as so.
You just say Cilk reducer,
the sum monoid
you've defined and x.
And now, the local view of x
can be accessed as x open
close parenthesis.
Now, in the example I showed
you, you didn't need to do the
open close parenthesis.
And the way you get rid of those
open close parenthesis
is you define a wrapper class.
So it's generally inconvenient
to replace every access with x
over brown.
That's one issue.
The other thing is accesses
aren't safe.
Nothing prevents a programmer
from writing x times equals 2,
even though the reducer
was defined over plus.
And that will screw up the
logic of this code if
somewhere he's multiplying
when, in fact, it's only
supposed to be combined
with addition.
So the way you solve that
is with a wrapper class.
You can do a wrapper class that
will protect all of the
operations inside and export
things that you can just refer
to the variable.
And it will actually
call that.
For most of what you're doing,
you probably don't need to
write a wrapper class.
You'll do fine just operating
with the extra parentheses.
In addition, there's
a whole bunch of
commonly use reducers.
Lists, appends, max, min, adds,
an output stream, and
some strings, and also you can
roll your own using things.
One issue with addition
is that, in fact,
this doesn't preserve--
for floating point addition--
does not
preserve the same answer.
And the reason is because
floating point numbers are not
associative.
If I had a to b and add that
to c, I can get something
different because of round off
error from adding a to the
result of b and c.
So generally, floating point
operations don't give you--
they'll give you something that
is close enough for most
things, but it's not actually
associative.
So you will get different
answers.
A quick example.
I'm sorry to run over
a little bit here.
I hope people have
a couple minutes.
Here's a real world example.
A company had a mechanical
assembly represented a tree of
assemblies down to
individual parts.
A pickup truck has all these
parts and all of these extra
subparts all the way down to
some geometric description of
what the part is.
And what they want to do is
the so-called collision
detection problem, which
has nothing to do
with colliding autos.
What they're doing is saying,
find collisions between the
assembly and a target object.
And that object might be
something like a half space
because they're computing
a cutaway.
Tell me all the things that
fall within this.
Or maybe, here's an engine
compartment, and does the
engine fit in with it?
So here's a code
that does that.
Basically, it does a recursive
walk, where it looks to see
whether it's an internal
node or a leaf.
If it's a leaf, it says, oh,
let me check to see whether
the target collides
with a particular
element of the tree.
And if so, add that object
to the end of a list.
So this is the standard a C++
library for putting something
on the end of the list.
If it's an internal node, then
go through all of the children
recursively.
And walk the children
So basically, you're going to
look through the whole tree.
Does it intersect this
particular object, x?
So how do we parallelize this?
We can parallelize
the recursion.
We turn the 4 loop here
into a Cilk 4.
So it goes through all the
children at the same time.
They all can do their
comparisons
completely the same.
Oops, but we have a bug.
What's the bug?
AUDIENCE: Is it push back?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The push back here.
We have a race here because
they're all trying to push on
to this output list
at the same time.
So we could resolve it with
a lock or whatever.
But it turns out it's much
better to resolve it with a--
so we could do this, right?
But now, you've got
lock contention.
And also, the list ends
up getting produced
in a jumbled order.
So it turns out if you use a
reducer, you declare this to
be a reducer with list append.
And what happens then is turns
out list concatenation is
associative.
If I concatenate a to b, and
then concatenate c, that's the
same as concatenating a to the
concatenation of b and c.
And I can concatenate lists in
constant time by keeping a
pointer to the head and
tail of each list.
So if you do that, and that
turns out to be one of the
built in functions, then, in
fact, this code operates
perfectly well with no
contention and so forth.
And in fact, produces the output
in the same order as
the original C++.
It runs fast.
And there's a little description
of how it works.
The actual protocol
is kind of tricky.
And we'll put the paper--
let's make sure we get this
paper up on the web.
I think it was there
from last year.
So we should be able
to find it.
If you're interested in
how the details work.
Here's the important thing
to know from a
programmer point of view.
So typically, the cost--
it turns out the reduce
operations you're only calling
when there's actually a steal.
It's actually a return
from a steal.
But since stealing occurs
relatively infrequently the
load balance, the number of
times you actually do one of
these reduce operations
is small.
The most of the cost is actually
accessing the reducer
to do the updates.
And it's never worse than a hash
table lookup the way it's
implemented.
If the reducer is accessed
several times within a region
of code, the compiler can
optimize the lookups using
common subexpression
elimination.
And in the common case, then,
what happens is it basically
has an access cost equal to
one additional level of
indirection, which is typically
an L1 cache hit.
So the overhead of actually
updating one of these things
is really just like an extra L1
cache hit for most of these
things, for most of the time.
If you have the case that you're
accessing a reducer
several times within the
same block of code.
Otherwise, at the very worst,
you have to actually do a hash
table lookup.
And that tends to be a little
bit more like a function call
overhead just in terms of
order of magnitude.
Sorry for running over.